yo
can you hear me
yo
yo yo can you hear me
can you hear me
can't hear me you can't hear me
all right what about now
the the ch
you sound uh a little high actually
mm-hmm
yeah
now a little bit higher
a little bit lower just a share
yes
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
his traveling mike uh go and talk
cognito
all right talk again
yo yo yo what's going on it's your boy
just want to know how it sounds he's not
going to be on the show just to clarify
he just wants to know how the the
the actual
uh the mic sounds cause he's got to do
this
give me the levels
let me know the levels
he says it sounds good
all right let's see
yeah
yeah listen back on it
that's what's up
well i'll see y'all in there flash going
only an extra flame up in there
shiny dirt heads no doubt
okay okay that's what's up
so you have a chat talking i got my
playstation
what's up i put the uh
the camera on there too so you can see
your camera yeah i see you got
playstation price increase oh there's a
little good show i gotta record
it's a good show to be on what's up flay
hey what's up
what's going on
anyway
yeah i get a little preview you know
what i'm saying hello
exclusive for the jerk
secret dlc cognito for a few hours
limited time
nft
yeah i'm van omt right now
i might not want to see it lame say
attic raise yourself a little come only
on xbox don't do that raise myself do i
sound
i don't i don't
i think i think you just talk it low oh
yeah i'm not i wasn't talking yet at all
see what's funny is like
naturally i i don't talk loud so
it's just like
and i think it's just
you know grace always tells me you know
you don't raise your voice a lot it's
like yeah you talk really low boys
that's all that
no doubt listen i want to join the show
i'm technically on vacation so to speak
but i got this package um your volume
okay
i could up it no i'm talking
about okay
he's oh sick oh what's up sir you're
sick up in there you know what does that
sound better guys let me know oh yeah
am i am i am i
peeking do i sound fine
i think if you yell or raise your voice
you might be all right
perfect all right well i'll just not
raise my voice
yeah if you keep it at your low tone
then you'll be fine but i know how you
get but guys you know these guys when
you start going on your
but
rent
i'll just i'll just turn it down
it's so hard to like manage everyone's
expectations
i can only do so much
absolutely there's
going on say what's up the dirk before i
bounce
yo what's up homie what's going on
quality control
got to see if you behave it
yeah
iop quality control what's going on yeah
it's too much tts in here what's going
on a lot of tt hasn't gone
just so the chat knows call does not
dictate my show i could be
as messy as i wanted
quality control a little network
might pop up through here and say you
know
as long as i ain't being too too much
you know we good we good it's your show
bro you ready how are you yeah but if i
started calling people yeah but if you
start wiley
did you really yeah i'm sorry carl i
don't know what happened man
call some people some pos right hey
having attic is your bed is like you
wake up you like who we beefing with now
hey i haven't really beat with anyone in
a while so
i've been oh yeah i've been stuck you
gotta kick your attic as friends you
just don't know who that is
like you never know
i guess i'll never know
like what beef have i inherited today
exactly
exactly
yeah king will be here momentarily oh
yes oh that's going to be late
for the show i got to do dude
he's upset we're not having iop this
week and he wants to get his bars off so
he's like i guess we'll do it on the
attic show
oh yeah that makes sense to say i'm
assuming playstation
oh that's half the show
all right i already know what it is
i'm doing quality control on the network
hey this ain't show
[ __ ] that's too much greenery going on
the ray
the raytrace twins is in the building
i don't like this man i don't like this
get out of here
somebody hit the boot but
[Music]
you're on vacation get up out of
[Laughter]
give me the violation red flag on me
it's about to get yourself
i
i was telling uh uh dirt it's like
sometimes man sometimes stuff just
happens man it can't help it man
sometimes it just happens
it's inevitable
what happened real quick cause i see it
i just got i just look right
so listen i got the real god
there's a greek god there's a female god
i got the real god this is what she with
a real god please stand up
this is what she look like
right
okay okay okay
they said nah let's blackface that oh
man
are we doing this
no i'm not no listen oh god i'm not all
right i just finished watching andrew
tate's whole story so
[Music]
big clown what up
yeah man [ __ ] what up real quick for
how far i bounce
so you're fighting everything good you
good right yeah everything good
everything good just making sure that
the travel bike was lit and then i got
to do duke now and then uh i was i
figured you know what let me just let me
holla you know that's a real quick
bottled water
yeah yeah i'm crashing don't do it
because they gonna try to do you like
they did jordan
[Laughter]
they gonna start sending me the bad
pizza
daddy
lean on me
saw the chat saw saw the the the topics
it was like i gotta leave this i can't
be part of this well he he better know
oh you got his super chat
let me play with your joystick five
alice who is this off-brand king david
who has replaced my song
it's all y'all
[Laughter]
oh god well hello
all
right right oh god what's going on you
guys i got i gotta change the boxes
again can't have people coming in and
out uh but yeah it won't take too long
what's going on guys you know we don't
got dirt long so we're gonna go ahead
and uh you know skip the formations man
we're gonna get into this show got a two
dollar super chat from
uh the angry therapist md tts uh what
let's go out to you man and then
obviously we've got the let me uh let me
play with your joystick with the five
dollars who is that off-brand king david
who has replaced my solve
okay i'm not gonna even address that so
what's going on you guys what's he
talking about me he's talking about me i
don't know if you talk about you or
[ __ ] i know he ain't talking about my
ray tway's twin brother
i don't know man but we gonna see it
right past that what's going on you guys
is the attitude where we talk about the
past present and future of gaming i got
dirt griggy to hear what's going on dirk
goody what's up man
i told you i was gonna try to i was
gonna try my best to make it uh you know
i'm here i can't say the whole show but
i'm going to try to say i'm going to try
to stay as long as i can let's go baby
then we got
big cloud gaming what's going on [ __ ]
yes sir just turned 30. i'm chilling
what's up
the ps3 just came out
yo yo yo
i want you right now to look at your
knees
this is the last great years of those
jokes
i stubbed my toe i already felt it
if you play basketball then you got five
more years
we got king david from the iron lord's
part cass coming his beard i don't know
why he's doing it like you know what
right before you get it's like lebron
you know like oh now this is just what i
do
i grease my beard up
[Laughter]
so oh man obviously you know we got a
stack show for you guys we got we go
people want us to talk a little bit
about the you know uh death loop we'll
talk about that later because i think
that's probably one of the lesser things
we got the playstation price increase
obviously we're gonna
talk about that and then we got the
playstation buy more studios and i'm
gonna ask king does anyone care and then
we got xbox family plan you know we're
gonna
go into that a little bit uh you know
since dirt man since you leaving in a
little bit which one you want to do
what's the one you want to talk about
hey man i mean listen we might as well
get it out the way right
okay let's talk about this price
increase you know it's been the hottest
hot topic for the last week and it's
it's starting to fade a little bit oh
boy i'm sweating
oh man
let's just talk about him man you know
all right so so so dirt which uh for for
those of you that's been sitting under a
rock under a rock under a rock uh there
is
this thing going on right now where a
playstation has
you know the they low-key ha ha dropped
some stealth stealth increases now
looked at they didn't come out and
informed people yes it was three in the
morning so i'm assuming some people
didn't see that all i'm telling you is i
didn't see it i might act dumb when i go
in there and see thank you
the good thing right now is it has been
increased in certain regions of north
america
is not one of those regions uh you know
we're going to keep that in mind so dark
green
what's your thought process on this
amazing day for xbox fans
the audacity
now
first off alex said it they dropped it
three o'clock in the morning
you know how you get up
take a piss in the middle of night you
know big claw you probably about to
start experiencing that soon you got to
piss in the middle of the night
started last night
so you know you know take a piss come
back in the bed look at the phone
saw my dm i saw a wbz dm you know my boy
sean is in the uk so he's eight o'clock
in the morning for him
i said wait a minute y'all had to kind
of wipe the boogers out my eyes a little
bit
does this say what i think it says
no no way are they really raising the
price
so after i saw that i didn't go back to
sleep
yo dirt tell me that wasn't one of those
moments where you like this can't be
real like this this can't be real
someone is trolling me someone is
putting like i have gotten one of those
things where someone has mimicked an
account and they put like the little
clock to make a check mark and they're
they're trolling the internet
but it wasn't a troll it's real
it wasn't a troll and look i have to
make sure because
it was quiet it was three o'clock in the
morning so a lot of the people in the
states wasn't up yet you know we had
some people overseas that was obviously
up then i saw it was official
playstation and not just that
your boy king your boy
yes
your boy wrote the blog i said well
listen now at the end of the day
they're doing what they have to do right
yeah they're doing what they have to do
they don't have to do that so
cog has left the building all right
this is this is equivalent this is
equivalent this is the personal left
right
this is equivalent of being that night
staff where you don't have to see the
management okay
yeah you look
so
i
i was in awe i couldn't believe it now
we heard you know like we know a couple
weeks ago they were asked about it and
they said no comment
but not i just didn't think
that they would really raise the price
hey i'm 45 years old i've seen every
council generation i don't remember one
console going up in price after two
years is it me
i don't i i don't remember that cogs
like i'm still watching you
i don't see nothing man we don't we we
see non we don't see color we don't he
ain't there
[Laughter]
um i'm a little bit older than you
and that's correct sir okay okay i want
to make sure
this is the only console manufacturer
that has pulled this crap twice in 2014
they did a stealth increase
in canada
um
on the playstation 4.
oh no i didn't use google i have my
sleuths in the streets
but sir
i'm gonna allow you to keep on
elaborating because i'm going to break
it down in such a sinister manner and
i'm gonna tell you how disgusting these
practices are and exactly what we should
look out for and why they are doing it
um
i'm i'm very interested to hear your
take but i'm just gonna say this
the um
the arrogance the
things that they've done this generation
so far
that word the audacity the audacity
those sobs now look i understand some
things they're doing this generation
some playstation fanboys is okay with
anything they do
but you know from seventy dollar games
to
you know uh uh like what's some of the
other stuff they did at the same time
accessories uh
accessories
i'm missing something with no real
benefits i'm missing something what am i
missing
damn it what do you mean
the ps5 tax
oh yeah yeah the ps5 taxi you
let's be honest guys you guys say it all
the time every generation is different
every generation is different and the
goalpost moves yeah and it moves you
can't automatically assume because
you're dominating you know you dominated
last generation you're still selling
well this generation you can't assume
that fans won't say hey you know what
i don't you know
we don't have to kiss your ass no more
it's listen there are millions of people
that haven't upgraded yet they're still
on the ps4
how many millions but they don't need to
know because everything they do because
they believe in generations
this is how strong this man's is on the
internet right now we got a dollar super
trap from andrew
they don't need to upgrade they believe
in generations the last generation
[Laughter]
listen bro they listen i love the last
of us but they re-bleached
they re-bleached the last of us and sold
it for seventy dollars and said you're
gonna buy it and those guys are gonna
buy it i'm gonna tell you why and they
did buy it not gonna lie by the way the
last of us remakes it looks i'm gonna
get it yeah
right and i'm not
this is no cap on it
oh he got it early and he he said that
there was no real change no it's not it
was yeah graphically it looks great it
looks like the last ones too though yeah
it's just it could have been done on the
ps4 though right already
that's all it is more polish but i
that's all i wanted for because 70
dollars i i don't have the old copy or
maybe i do
of the last of us and i want it at the
60 frames per second
at um 120 frames per second you play i
mean um yeah 120 frames it's uh
something like a input of 40. have you
played it at 120 hertz is uh yeah 40
frames per second but
regardless to what
um the work that is put into it because
i just watched digital foundry right and
the work that is put into it is it worth
seventy dollars no it'll be a black
friday special on the kid you know
that'll happen it's twenty dollars two
more too much that's what i look at but
yeah but it's something that i would own
right and i think the meta score of the
game actually reflects
the the consensus
around everyone it's not even the
complete project uh you're missing the
multiplayer
but yeah go sorry dirk i do i don't
think the quality of the game is is the
question right now yeah because yes the
game graphically looks better it looks
like it it looks like the last of us too
in my opinion which it looks amazing um
but like big cloud just said taking out
the multiplayer
and still charging 70 i think it's you
know this they're they're showing there
yeah they don't give a damn about what
people think this generation their
playstation they're going to do what
they want to do and look
everybody know i'm a bot but i enjoy the
playstation brand i do i'm just being
honest about it but at the same time
i remember them in the ps3 generation at
least the beginning of the ps3
generation
some of that arrogance is kind of
leaking a little bit man i mean this is
my opinion it's leaking a little bit and
listen man they are still still like the
you know they're dominating they're
selling great but
i'm just saying everything is not set in
stone things can change people can't
change their feelings and them casuals
still haven't upgraded yet
and the casuals they're not brand loyal
like us
yeah that's right i mean because there's
nothing to upgrade for there's
absolutely no reason to do said things
you know and to have the arrogance to
believe that a tv show will make
somebody run out and play uh over 700
dollars is it's arrogance within itself
you know it's is that the highest level
um a tv show is not going to equate to
extra sales it won't it will it it will
equate to sales on existing customers
that's what might happen but there are
some numbers already in your ecosystem
so for them not to know your biggest
titles
it screams of arrogance the unmitigated
gall
of these individuals how many you're
gonna break up marvel i thought they
just spent a little too much time on
marvel because now tomorrow would just
call it lightning in a bottle with the
tv
and it's other characters but it's
different
you know it's it's it's a different
thought process when it goes into this
for for the for two years
for two years these dudes have did
console revisions for two years
stealthily revised the hardware giving
you cheaper material lightening up the
product the product's still the same
size
right that's why that is coming
eventually but they're taking stuff out
of the product and giving you an
inferior product and raise the price on
an inferior part this is where the
sinister part comes in
right because they give you the thought
the thought process on a casual consumer
going into the store looking for a
playstation 5 is saying okay this is
what i want this is what i'm going to
get they have absolutely no idea
this is not the same product that you
were seeking in the beginning
why is this product 50 more because they
became the scalpers like addicts said
before they've looked at the scalpers
and they said the scalpers is making all
this bread
let's let's start making more money off
of these scalpers right let's start
making money off of these territories
that we are winning it this the most
disgusting part about this is
you're already winning in these
territories yeah but the territory that
you're having the most trouble in said
now i'm not gonna raise those prices
yeah that's like it's like it's like
winning
there that's like winning award instead
of doubling down on the army and these
territories like you're pulling
civilization you're just gonna raise the
taxes like
that's absolutely disgusting
then they do these practices with the
games
they they're actually penalizing the
playstation 5 owner
by charging them
to use the features
that you featured
you told them the haptic feedback in the
controller this was must have
changed the experience yep and the crazy
thing about ten dollars more ten dollars
more the crazy part is like they're
they're doing like underhand shady
marketing too like you know when you buy
an xbox game right now
go go to the store it's literally one
xbox game is everything it's it's
they even started promoting xbox 360
games bringing them back calling them
xbox one games because technically it's
on the backwards compatibility list but
you can go to the store and you'll buy a
ps4 game
and they won't tell you that you can
upgrade it for free and the charges will
be different in the store so you can get
horizon which is an actual
60 game and if you didn't know no better
you wouldn't know to buy the ps4 version
just get the natural upgrade for free to
the ps5 version you would just spend the
extra ten dollars to get the ps500
because your mindsets like i bought this
ps5 i guess i want the ps5 version
and that's what i said like i'm not
telling you right yeah me and king had a
conversation months ago
playstation
is penalizing you for early adopting
their console the people that went out
there they sat in those lines they
bought this
they bought the scalp versions of them
for for a thousand dollars plus they are
penalizing them people for making sure
they had their platform in the first
year of its life cycle and you still see
it happening now now it's like yeah
the worst thing they're doing sorry for
cutting you off
they're paralyzing the early adopter
and now they're penalizing the dude that
waited
hmm yeah you're writing for the sale
like you're waiting for the sale for the
sale
yeah and there's no guarantee you'll get
one still no
guarantee so you so you can wait in line
sign up for this newsletter for
playstation there's no guarantee you
will get your hands on the ps5 you'll
notice king
they did it right before holiday no no
no
hell with that
the hell with that part this is the most
disgusting part about it
they raised the price
now you see the console's popping up
oh fast
facts bro exactly i even think about
that you're speaking about how do you
think about that you're speaking about
that
you notice how the council's p that's
that's really stocking up right or the
500 you know the 500 model yeah where is
the where is the where's the slim or
should i see the digital where's the
digital
we talked to um we talked to forte on
iop last week and he said
like from his experience obviously he
doesn't control every game but he
manages the game stop and he said for
every one
ps5 regular uh digital version there's
five ps5 bulk versions that have the uh
the disc tray in it and what's funny is
not only did they raise that that price
point
they have these horizon bundles that you
can only realistically buy like when you
actually go to buy the ps5 uh from like
the you know the little q thing they
have on their website they don't offer
you regular ps5s they are
horizon bundles for 550. and guess what
they go
guess what they got your controller
guess what guess what they're going to
do in a year king will we
we sold five million plus horizons
like
when they did it with the 20 minute
plank
they they're going to do what they did
now imagine the horizon imagine the
price on top of these bundles yeah it's
it's it's a very slimy practice from
what i'm seeing
and i don't think this is how you reward
your your dudes that's sitting at the pc
or that's going down to the stores
and waiting
there i i saw the mighty keith he did
something that had me almost pee on
myself
you know the dude went inside the store
and he saved though he had the skit the
dude saved up his money went inside the
store and he was like yo i got the
newsletter they told me that you got it
uh you know the email i'm here for it
and the dude's like what what you want
the store uh clerk and he's like well
the playstation 5 they said you have he
said yeah he brought it out the box he
was like here you go and he was like
yeah here you go that's uh 550 bucks you
know with the tax and he was like nah
baby
[Laughter]
he's like what do you mean he's like
yeah he took that back and the next dude
was like i got that money and he sold
the the joint in front of his face and
got a meltdown i'm just saying
these practices i've never seen this in
console history to be honest with you
never that uh old model
and this is the new model the new
monster the revised model with less
stuff inside it's selling more than the
actual model that it replaced absolutely
never seen this self-replacement and
things justifying and saying that oh
it's an expensive hobby oh you're a
broke boy you can't afford a place down
why are they gonna shame you why why are
we getting shamed
that's not i'm sorry all i said
it's just dudes that's all
man
hey hey king man you said something that
i didn't even think about
after this price increase all of a
sudden you're starting to see more
playstation 5's available now yeah yeah
i didn't think about that yeah you're
right bro they popped up around my area
but it's my area don't count though it's
it's like
it's like they contacted all these
warehouses like look i know we just had
a huge shipment for the holidays hold
them suckers we've got to raise the
price man i know you got 20 million
about to go out there for holiday hold
the majority of them let them have a
million and you know what you know what
we want more money so let's let's bundle
on horizon with that million let's do
that let's do that oh oh okay
gamestop once okay give them a million
cause they gonna bundle a bunch of our
[ __ ] on them too but it's okay we all
gonna win imagine
if these dudes
is really sony
oh my god
if these dudes is really sony and it was
like yeah we go we're gonna drop it when
we raise the price b
[Laughter]
you don't want to go to stockx or we're
gonna bring stockx to you exactly there
you go yo yo king merrell we talk
i said it's on uh
y'all were live uh saturday but i got
the super chat but i was like yo notice
how everybody has a degree all of a
sudden something for example whenever
they change the the internals right with
the heatsink oh dudes got degrees and
thermodynamics right then we got dudes
got degrees in business when they're
doing all this what was it what
mike micro economy yeah micronutrients
now you got degrees in economics okay if
you got degrees in economics you know
that if the inflation was affecting
playstation the way they said it was
we also would have got a pricing global
well here there had been a global price
increase globally not areas
on xbox and two to three
that's the part that's what part to tell
you yeah exactly
but people people like oh no it's it's
they're doing that because you know the
the the almighty u.s dollar is is better
no
really that was the case
look what i think is that's enough money
for a company no they will go for what
they can get hold up someone said
there's uh it's not colorblind breaking
protocol no we got color we got a color
no no i got the color but let me let me
let me get this eric the beard dude does
attic realize the rest of the world
doesn't celebrate christmas anyone want
to tell them look i agree with you but
there's a lot of hanukkahs around that
time of the year like there's a lot of
stuff people celebrate around that time
of the year like
i celebrate
yeah and not to mention even though you
don't celebrate christmas around that
time of the year
these companies are still going to
assume you do and you're still going to
get the same deals let's stop acting
like there's not deals to be made black
friday exists in a lot of countries it
might not be called black friday
everywhere else but at the same concept
still is everywhere exactly let me get
these super chats real quick we got a
two dollar subject from the angry
therapist md
and they said smart delivery was fake
you know what
coming back to think about that that's
that's that's
playstation does the exact same thing
it's a buzzword quick resume that's a
buzzword too right yeah i can jump in my
game a whole lot faster than that super
ssd that you got and my boy came over
and he saw me do it and he said what the
hell did you just do
and i thought the playstation was fast
he said i got it because the playstation
was faster i said you're a fast idiot
that's all you are i said i got my
playstation there too i have not seen a
speed that they talked about but god
bless you know one thing let me get this
super chat real quick uh i do agree with
you like that is probably that's why i
said you go to walmart there's one game
it doesn't matter what it is you go to
gamestop it's like it's a ps4 version
ps4 pro version like what's funny is the
the the smart deadlift was so
crazy that i know people that were
downloading the game and it was giving
them the ps4 version and it was saying
the ps5 version so it's like look like
at the end of the day play xbox realized
look we want to come out next
next generation swinging and they were
swinging they were definitely swimming
we got a final switch from iron mike nah
we're really going to be nasty is when
only temporarily dropped the ps5 to the
original price for black friday sales
and they go back up in january oh no and
i even i even have one better for you
iron mike they're going to eventually
drop the price to the original price and
act like we're supposed to pat them on
the back for that
yeah
like this
man
for black friday you're gonna buy it at
the original price it's gonna go right
back up and then when they actually do a
price cut they're going to cut that's
when they're going to raise the price in
the united states
when it's time for a price cut you know
what's even more funny though so the
price hike happens after they announced
the uh playstation pro edge controller
yeah and i know and i have my thoughts
and i was okay so that control is
probably gonna be like what 150 180 type
of thing that thing yeah this bike will
be 200 there's gonna be 200 dollars when
it drops because they told me it comes
with a charging case i'm like
oh gee what about the vr like how
yeah i told dudes before i thought that
was gonna be didn't i say 900 dollars
totally like 900 because it would be
like yeah
and stuff like that so i thought it was
going to be 900 it looked like it's a
smooth 1k it looked like a smooth 1k
going in there once again
whoa
that bundle i don't man
cause you forget about that you know
that's going to happen man they did it
with the ps4 right cracker you got like
a bundle with it so i would i wouldn't
be surprised well i'm i'm gonna get i'm
gonna be able to pick mine up because a
lot of these first of all i blame all
you lazy dudes all you lazy dudes that
said i'm gonna sit next to the pc and
i'm gonna order my joint and i'm going
to get it and it's going to come in the
mail and you didn't want to actually go
out and put out the work you didn't want
to go stand on the line oh i can't take
the game off the day off from work oh i
got to spend time with my girlfriend oh
all my bunions hurt or whatever excuses
you came up with this is exactly what
you get right here a head knock boom
this is you for sitting there thinking
you wasn't gonna get a date you was
gonna get a day one by sitting at your
pc you didn't now
you're sitting here and seeing exactly
what sony is doing to you you thought
you was gonna wait well i get it later
because it's not too much stuff out
right now and i get it later when
there's a price drop you woke up in the
morning and said the price went up on a
brick and
i see i had the same story as dirk i got
up to go pee because that's what old men
do we get up and go pee in the night
so my dms is lit i'm like why the hell i
got like 20 messages on twitter right
and it's all dms usually that's like in
in the mentions right i'm like what what
and they all send me the same thing and
then even the person that posted it
send me a dm like really and i'm looking
like oh
all right
all they can say is you got material for
sunday
let me let me address the chat um that
was an attack on eric the beard uh chat
relax
you know
he was just giving his opinion his
opinion isn't wrong i'm just saying that
they they target holidays for more than
just christmas they target holidays
because that's when people are open to
spending money like that it's not
necessarily about christmas that's why i
said holiday listen that's the time when
people get their bonuses you get your
bonuses at the end of the day this is
fiscal period right y'all
now y'all want to talk business right
you little micro economic
dudes y'all got businesses okay let me
tell you so they got a degree in
thermodynamics yeah right
yeah the heat sink can try to place
things
around
the cpu when it cools it off when it
grabs it anyway
[Laughter]
what i would tell you is
at the end this is the reason why you
get bonuses
it's the same reason why at the end of
the year you tax dump it's the same
thing
it's a write-off
you look at your books you see exactly
where your books is at and you say
listen i got to be under a certain
number
in order to get this tax break here or
edit and able to get this benefit so
when you do fight taxes the next season
the next fixed school period because
this is the end of that fiscal period
that's where the taxes come in at
you give everybody their bonuses
that's a book that's off the books boom
boom boom boom boom everything falls off
the books then your high margin that you
made in that year drops below that point
where you would have been penalized
this is why the holiday
can give you get that money exactly ken
giving you knowledge you used to have to
use that to pay someone for a course you
can go to school for
right
right y'all think y'all winning but what
do y'all do anytime you get a bonus
you fools go out and give it right back
to the corporations
so they see inflated sales numbers
during this period of time because you
have more cash to spend because the
companies dump more money into the into
the populace this is exactly reason why
it has nothing to do with some religious
stuff and how you feel about the
holidays and the solstices we want to
feel good about that they fool us into
believing that but that's not the key
the key is actually it has everything to
do revolving around the business and the
business is the key so
you're not you're not wrong beard mike
tyson beard that's mike tyson beard
right
oh oh oh oh what about aaron
eric the bear you're not wrong you're
actually right but the way they fool the
consumer they fool the consumer into
believing that it's a holiday thing when
it's more of a business thing yeah
it's like i said um
i personally feel like when it comes to
the price increase
i think that
anyone that's believing this is purely
for inflation reasons is delusional
if it was for inflation they would have
they would have increased it everywhere
absolutely
yeah and what's funny is people are like
but addict you know they're they're
competing in in
they actually have competition in north
america okay
that's one of their highest selling
margins
like not
not increasing it in america
is probably going to be the most like if
it was truly for inflation not
increasing it in america is the most
contradicting thing ever because that's
probably
either their best selling market or
their second best-selling market so you
don't you you go and then like look like
we we we're having really bad issues
with inflation costs her up we need to
raise everywhere what about america not
there but that's literally probably 70
60 70 percent of our market that's
what's going on the best deal in gaming
when your entry-level price is higher
than everybody else's
nintendo is increasing the price
nintendo we know nintendo do do the most
shady stuff in this industry they sold
you cardboard for 80 bucks and who's
defended it they sold you re-releases
at up price and gave you a time limit to
get it and no discounts
none they never had discounts i gotta
win
right now i can sell for five hundred
dollars
they said no nintendo's the last person
you would expect to be like they didn't
know their price so
ending this conversation i don't know
how much longer we have dirt um
i do want to ask you all
do you think
the hubris is there enough where they
might potentially get too full of
himself and repeat a ps3 generation dirt
what's happening now
like king said i'm noticing it right now
man like this stuff
i mentioned all the time on my channel
on
on my podcast this is stuff that we
lived right
when the ps3 came out i just said i was
big cloud x just turned 30.
we witnessed what happened with the ps3
now this is coming off of the ps2
generation
ps2 generation was absolutely incredible
for them yeah yeah
but my point is that
of course we have our die hard
uh playstation fanboys our die hard xbox
fans but at the same time
people will turn on you
uh we can't take for granted because
it's the playstation they dominate
that people won't say hey you ought to
piss me off because people hey well that
ps3 generation the first few years they
people wasn't rocking with the ps3 like
besides the hardcore playstation guys
even after the wii
people wasn't rocking with that wii u
bro
like the we sold 100 million the wii you
sold 13 million i was come on part of
that you say you wanted a 13 i got the
original
so my point is
playstation better be very helpful yes
they're they're a juggernaut in this
image in this industry they make great
exclusives uh but at the same time man
if you get all these people bad side and
i mention if the casuals decide to go
with xbox
series s series x this generation
they're they're gonna be in trouble so
they're they really need to be very
careful because so far this generation
they've made some decisions
that's pissing people off
and if you get to a point
well i don't know man
like they're going to have to really
like it took them the whole ps3
generation to really
get their stuff together
right
and
mark cerny helped him
you know
yeah but like even with the xbox 360
people love the xbox 360. even
throughout the red rings of death people
still love the 360. yeah the xbox one
dropped years it pushed sony to the best
peak they ever been and we got some of
the best bangers out of playstation at
that time yeah so that's what's only
needed like tony's afraid of getting
pushed
back in the lockers like they were with
the 360. they yesterday that's what
they're fearing
that type of competition though to get
back yeah absolutely how
absolutely how they've been acting
i actually feel like there's a strong
chance that
they
they screw themselves out of this
generation this is the last this is
definitely possible because
here's my thing okay when it was just
making people pay to access features
that you promoted on your playstation
that's one thing when it was just
you know
doing the things where they were doing
with the fan with the with the plans on
the the playstation plus and extra uh
you know they they withholding the
ability to buy those like they've
they've had for years and i get it like
look like you know people are finessing
but it's like you knew that was gonna
happen like you mean to tell me a
multi-billion dollar corporation didn't
expect people to buy those by by the
dozens and just redo them you may you
may not expect me to believe that like
they had every intentions on you buying
these and limiting how you could use
them they had every intentions on it
there's no way a company like that
doesn't understand that that's going to
happen microsoft did they're like look
if anything i see that is you being part
of my service for this foreseeable
future do it we we full you can only do
it once but do it you know and it's just
like and then you look at this where
they're just raising prices when
the reason to raising prices doesn't
make sense like i said if it was for
inflation it would have been globally
not just where they're losing not just
where they're winning it would have been
globally and it's just like little
things like this and then you look at
you know we're going to talk about play
uh last of us part one you see stuff
where they are
literally
taking trophies out of games they're
they're taking i i saw this one thing uh
where this dude kicked in
uh joe at one point at the time kicked
in the door and it shook the screen in
the original one and made all this loud
noise and it literally sounded so bad
there was no screen it's like they're
they're
it's like they're taking a reign and
it's like anything even remotely violent
we're gonna pull it back
and it's just like if people think that
they're gonna do something like this
bringing it back for a remake you don't
think they're gonna do that for future
naughty dog games i mean look at look
it's uh everything's gonna get a remake
at this point because it's gonna say in
development for pc at the bottom so the
last of us two is next why should be one
well ready got we already got spiderman
out the way miles morales is next
untreated
look at him they're going to lose
look at god of war god of war went from
one of the most gory games in existence
and they won't even let you fight humans
anymore like when they pacify them
yeah
we're living in a society where you know
toxic masculinity is not the thing and i
get it that's where we that's where
we're at right now we're no longer in
the action film guy stage that's good i
don't care you know to be honest with
you if that's where we're moving as a
society uh the number one medium in
which we consume our uh stuff
entertainment is video games so the
video games will reflect our society
that's exactly where we are right now so
i'm not going to really get too upset
with the fact that they they're toning
down the gore and they're doing this
that in the third and and i get that and
i and i feel that because they have it
has a place in certain things right and
and i feel your outrage um
same people ain't making the game same
people ain't running the company yeah um
and and we we really gotta accept that
part right yeah we're gonna see that
we're a rock star as well they're
abandoning the fat boy mentality that's
what i'm like yeah i don't know what to
expect from gta 6 but but but this thing
is it is it's just the practices of
taking your fan base and somebody told
me well
i'm having fake outrage because i have a
playstation and i shouldn't care so if
you're getting your butt whipped across
the street
and i see it
i i shouldn't stand up for you this is
the mentality of a coward you're a
coward that's the mentality of a coward
i'm not i don't care just because i got
mine i shouldn't say something just
because i got mine see this this is this
is the mentality of when they start
beating people up and taking people out
you don't say anything interesting
because it's until it's you
it affects if it affects one it affects
all we are community i don't i don't
care
i play playstation i play nintendo i'll
show you stuff that you've never seen
before that you didn't know that they
had i'll show you a playstation go a psp
go i got that you ain't got that you
ain't support the level i did but what
i'm saying is
these practices wasn't done in the past
with people that cared about the
consumer and what i'm seeing is this
company
has put people in place that don't play
games
right that's the thing
they don't identify with you which games
is your hobby in your life this is they
don't identify with you so they can use
you in any manner that they choose and
if you don't stand up for these
practices and you turn a blind eye it's
going to affect you in a manner that
you're not going to be comfortable with
at some point in time so if you stand
for one you stand for all and this is
the point in time where you're supposed
to stand up for all
so i named my video but i had dudes
saying oh it's not that big of a deal
it's not that nice
once they do the next joke so we forgot
no you're gonna forget about it i don't
forget about stuff like this i think the
uh dirt's gotta go dirt give you your i
gotta go i just got called out bro all
right man yeah
go to work man get that money man ray
twain
gave his opinion man he's gonna give me
a ps5
no no you gotta get that extra money you
gotta work a little over time to get the
ps5 now yeah i gotta work overtime to
get me another ps5 man
sony attacks to find one you know what i
mean all right fellas have a good shot
i'll be listening
yo everybody go out and check his new
video his new videos out he's gonna make
you pee on yourself again i'm going to
be talking that trash you know
all right fellas i'll be listening talk
to you guys all right so we're going to
go ahead and uh you know transition our
way into uh into this crazy because i
got a good little couple of topics here
we got to ten street from killer e305
sony increased the price of the ps5 530
so we can drop the price in the us come
holiday season to avoid taking a loss
for the price drop don't be surprised if
they increase the price of accessories
too you know people don't think about
accessories definitely something that
they can increase over time i mean right
now they they're finally getting their
own pro controller the playstation edge
which is interesting but you know let
let's go and let's talk about this thing
you know obviously we we don't get to
talk about this on iop this week because
uh there's no iop once again anyone in
the chat we're having a community today
instead of iop this sunday so right now
playstation uh hold up hold up
people people you know what's funny king
people are upset that i don't do time
stamps so now i'm starting to do time
stamps
during the show so there you go there's
the time stamp for this one all right so
playstation has bought
well let me
um savage game studios
now for those in the chat
i'm sure that you're like what's that
i'm glad you asked because i didn't know
either okay
they are a mobile studio that's in
germany um it doesn't do you know what
kind of games they've made in the past
uh
bitcoin
okay it's a mobile studio um and then
you know let's go and talk a little bit
about the
them investing in the from software that
was announced today apparently they've
invested in the from software and we
know that um people you know what's
funny people acted like because they
invested in the five 15 percent of from
software that they own from software
that's not how business works guys no
they they invested in the into fortnight
do you see anything going on there
and they actually own more
and epic than they do from software they
actually double down i mean they might
have tripled down i don't know so it's
just like you know i want to go to king
you know
i want to ask you king when you saw this
because clearly we see playstation they
they bind to we see all these companies
buying but we see xbox
buying
corporations buying publishers and then
you see something like this
and it's just it is i can't help but to
be a little bit disappointed because
it's just like dude a mobile game it's
just like you know and i know that i'm
sure this is going to change the people
who
who who work his lives i'm sure
hopefully you know their lives changed
for the better but to me i'm looking at
this i'm like
this isn't the direction i want
playstation to go like and that's why i
feel like when people say stuff like
attic they have the bangers that's
what's going to keep us going and i and
i bring up situations where we see with
the last of us where they're devaluing a
lot of violence you see it in god of war
are we guaranteed these bangers in the
future especially when they're investing
in like the mobile market like are they
trying to make mobile games are they
trying to make an accessibility for for
playstation to be played on mobiles what
do you think king
okay i don't i don't think we need to
ring the panic bell and saying that they
are uh
putting the tone down on the violence
when they have games like sifu would
actually just be but that wasn't made by
them though i know i mean but they they
championed it they put in a store like
it was uh part of the ecosystem and it
was something that they actually uh
marketed right so yeah um i'm not gonna
say
i'm i'm not at the the tipping point yet
i could be in the burning house drinking
tea don't know it okay so pretty much
you're like look we have some of
examples we can't go out the window
exactly let me let me let me see some
more stuff um
now
savage studios based in berlin uh they
they make a couple of games when they
went out and got nexus i championed
nexus
uh because i knew they were diversifying
their portfolio to get these games and
and produce them in the pc market uh
and and i knew
that changes how the playstation brand
because isn't it weird how when we we
talk playstation we say sony we include
sony and playstations money together but
when we talk xbox and microsoft they
want to separate the cash we're not
gonna do that all right um so microsoft
xbox same thing trillion dollar company
sony a billion dollar company and let me
explain why i said that
when you got billion dollars and you're
going up trailer going up against
trillion dollar companies you got to
make billion dollar guy moves
right which is a lot of moves yeah
these are some good moves that they're
making and i love the strategic aspects
of how uh jim is actually able to to to
slide into different situations and
maneuver in the way that he's doing so
he looks at uh stuff that aren't
producing and he cuts them off really
quickly japan not working cut you off
split you up have you do something else
and over here
they needed nexus he knew nix's
turnaround of rate on their games was
actually
high
they can get a game they can turn it
around at a high quality and spider-man
showed that spider-man showed that nexus
has the chops that they're able to do
this stuff and get this stuff turned
around at a quick amount of time because
you want to get that money you want to
be in that zeitgeist right
now savage
yeah i know you guys are going to say uh
microsoft got king when they finish this
deal with um
and a lot of dudes don't know people in
the chat king are saying savage is a
brand new company made two years ago and
even made a game yet so you can't even
compare them because like king is an
established company
hold on
hold on
let me attack it
okay you have a lot of dudes that don't
know activision
blizzard
king
that's why they say abk some of them
some dudes be just throwing out the
acronym and don't know what it is
king is the mobile unit of that part and
they have a pedigree they have chops
they have games that actually make money
microsoft money in that area is founded
that's a proven commodity
why wouldn't you want playstation
to see what this company can perform
what they can do
and actually
give
something back to the playstation brand
right so they so
they go and they invest in this area
that they're weakened we always complain
that they don't invest in areas that
they're weak in
they don't need to double down on a
single-player platform game or person
right they're already established in the
single player they need multiplayer they
need the other abs yeah they need that
too
yeah so now that they're doing it and i
and i applauded them i said yo go do
that
for the fools that said 14
inside from software isn't nothing
let me throw this right back at you
potentially they made game of the
generation that last game
you know that their next game is going
to be elder ring the next game is going
to be highly anticipated if it goes to
elder ring 2 or whatever the hell they
make next is going to be a highly
anticipated game that is going to sell
gangbusters so what you want to have in
on that wouldn't you want to put money
in on that if you can't buy them
outright this is a billion dollar
company not a trillion dollar company
exactly you put money in that
relationship you build that relationship
even further you expand on that they
already single-handedly killed uh the
horizon
by themselves so so
that's a power move these are power
moves when you're moving with a certain
amount of money
yeah right and i respect it and i
understand they're trying to survive
so
when i say this is the last playstation
console
and yeah
who cares i don't care
is it going to be the last game made by
playstation hell no no
they're going to live on in in
in in the way that they transform the
business you're seeing a transformation
happen right in front of your eyes they
dipping their hands in mobile they
dipping their hands in pc they dipping
their hands in services yep this is the
new model going forward yeah there's
already a report of a launcher uh
supposedly that was going to drop on the
vehicle the spider-man yeah it was
inspiring
but also they were talking about like it
was going around that you would probably
need a playstation network account yeah
yeah they'll link that to you get your
trophies and all that stuff so they
already think in the long term uh hall
of what you need to do to go for it and
again it's not
a bad thing it's just business they see
where everything's going the console
sells
yeah they they they're up there right
they continue to do well but there's a
limit to how far you can push a console
a lot of people are just not going to
buy a console you might peak the highest
they got was last year was like 120
something yeah 120 yeah 121 for ps4 i
don't think ps5 is gonna outdo ps4 it
might get up there with a hundred like
in the hundred range i doubt it
it's it'll be the schedule to do that
yeah there's a lot you need to do and by
the time we start getting into that
conversation
this is where microsoft has that
opportunity with just call of duty by
itself we already talked about this with
aggressive marketing with game pass all
you have to do is have a limited edition
console and have them legit go on stage
and say yeah by the way all call of duty
games
day one game pass one question that's it
do you remember when playstation had the
playstation now inside the xbr
television
they tested that out
yeah they did that before microsoft did
it with samsung and lg yep
so
they tested it out
that thing that we saw that isn't my
dm's about the browser
that can be an app inside the
playstation televisions and sony they
make the televisions it doesn't hurt
them to put it inside the television and
sell it with that controller a new
controller
mm-hmm
just something to think about
i feel like you know
it's doing an update on the showcase but
hey we get a controller update i feel i
feel like
the from software thing
there's purely a business move they they
want influence in the company and they
want profits from the company i'm sure
they'll get some kind of definitives
um i don't think that's necessarily
anything on a future tent now they could
instead of going doubling down like epic
did like they did with epic a couple
years ago for all you know in the next
year
they both feel like they profited off
each other they've got a good
relationship because of what's going on
then they then they buy them uh i don't
think that's going to be the case
because tencent bought some from them as
well
so i blocked them very quickly yeah yeah
and
keep in mind
tencent knows out of all the japanese
developers right now like single
developers now obviously they have a
they have a parent company but
they're definitely still an independent
company
um from software is probably the gold
mine everyone wants but no one can get
and i think that
yeah and i think that that's what it is
you know
they're not selling willingly and i
think that everyone it's kind of like
that that old days king where like in
the fairy tales where everyone has to
bring like the the best gift to the
hottest chick in the village to see who
she chooses like you know it was you
bring the fat pig to the to the dad to
see who gets the daughter
and it's like everyone's breeding this
fat pig known as buying
shares to from software to see who who
are from stockton's like oh i see you
over there sony i see you oh my gosh i
see you i see you tensing i see you
but i ain't giving nothing to any of you
like this they're not
so they're like ubisoft they're gonna
keep the 51 stake and sell off the rest
to the highest bidder
and i think that when it comes to the
mobile thing
i'm i'm conflicted with this i don't
know if they're doing this to make
mobile games or are they doing this to
get into the cloud streaming
infrastructure or you could play
playstation playstation games on uh
mobile it could be both it definitely
could be both
spider-man here
yeah but remember playstation showed
that like uh kind of like the the razer
kinchie thing yeah like they
they showed their own so like yeah
what's funny is like people sitting
there saying oh you know
what's gonna happen when sony makes a
game for pc and and platform it's going
to be less for some reason king and big
cloud i'm sure you've seen this people
have this assumption that triple a
developers with million dollars of
budgeting can't develop for two
to get two platforms at the same time
when publishers have been doing it for
decades
so
imagine now since they're going to start
making games for pc then they're going
to get that backdrop like yo
we want you to make this for the
streaming platform too like
i i can tell you where their fears lie
their fears lie in the slippage that
they're seeing in the playstation meta
scores
that mid 80s high 80s
this is where the meta score is right
now it's sales too because like these
games they're not selling like their
their predecessors they're not selling
10 million plus 10 million plus like
like look i don't try to get lightning
in a bottle twice especially when you
raise the price of it i don't think it
will be yeah exactly that i don't
understand i don't think we're unless
you're unless you're epic fortnight is
like
see that that's the thing that part
right there that that's what you're
saying see traditionally yeah we're
never going to reach those numbers but
the fortnight thing
is the games of service
that's true you can't be in it unless
you you can't win it unless you win it
right yeah so the fact that jim says
we're going to do 10 games as a service
i'm getting serviced yet and and we're
going to see how that goes
listen i i told somebody in the dms
and they was like you know i don't know
where they're going i said listen listen
don't be
shocked if you see
god of war
have some multiplayer component to it
don't be shocked if you see spider-man
has some multiplayer components yeah
like co-op something yeah some i mean
something further than that i'm talking
about an open world
where you can play
multiplayer spider-man's or whoever
swinging around oh like a multiverse
thing like they'll have like a spin yeah
that's true yeah that's true two two
to capitalize on that as because you to
make these
games that cost
you know
at least a hundred million dollars or
whatever how much they cost we don't
really know the actual figures but you
know because marketing and stuff is tied
to this stuff
but to make these games
you need to have recurring income coming
back because the initial sale point
especially if you're locking them into
bundles and stuff like that is not going
to have that har hard um roi that's
return on investment guys since y'all
like mike right on economic oh no
the roi is not going to be there but the
return on investment is higher on games
of a service and multiplayer games to
have a recurring uh turnaround base so
there could be some multiplayer aspects
to these games that they're not saying
because remember god was supposed to
come out in 2021
it got delayed for a reason still looks
the same yeah
but got delayed for a reason and is the
reason a multiplayer component that's
put on this game that allows you to play
at least a four player type card because
i remember sony being envious of gears
of wars multiplayer aspect of the
competitions game because god of war
gears of war is supposed to be the head
up go against each other type of stuff
uh when they're competing against
numbers yeah and if they can get a
component that is a multiplayer aspect
to these games
then they can have that returning uh
investment coming back so yeah i mean
remember the original with the nine
realms you know they can go to yes three
of the nine realm or something like that
yeah i never got it and the restaurant
yeah you couldn't go to anywhere else it
is still kind of weird that they would
even put that as an option
yeah like all these spots but you can't
turn the wheel to ascart you can't go to
uh i think you go to hellheim i don't
know you can go however about this
was the place
where you did the uh the the chicken
with the change yeah the chest thing
it's like look like
i still think playstation's in a good
spot right now
yeah but i find here they're not
affected yet i'm curious where they're
gonna be in a year and a half to two
years from now
i'm curious to see how
the next orderation of games that comes
out on the ps5 come out
because as we saw we saw horizon come
out it was just an amped up version of
zero dawn
you know and i feel like
we're getting to that point where xbox
was where we're seeing sequels
we're we're not seeing anything new and
original and you know microsoft still
has a little bit to go but i think they
have gotten away from that sure you're
seeing like out of outer worlds too
uh you're seeing um you know hellblade
too but then for those you got starfield
brand new ip you got uh you know games
that uh that the algorithm yeah redfall
brand new ip they are doing a little bit
of balance now i have said multiple
times got a five dollar switch out for
rubber knob
wait next up sony's going to buy 14 of
tc
yo
imagine if they deemed if if you know
that's all
yeah yo yo hold up imagine that's all
king would ever need to tell for that
i'm gonna google that i'll be right back
that that's that's all king would need
is for them to come out openly and say
that we
are deeming tcl the place to play
playstation imagine
king and how
epic he would be that day he would be
uncontrollable
but you know avowed another one you know
there's a there's plenty of games that
we can go through with that
so i mean that i think that's just you
know my
curiosity when it comes to it we got to
see exactly what happens in the future
with this company um i i don't think
it's like cause i don't think we're
we're we're quite there where it's like
the world's on fire it's not set in
stone yet they have a lot of stuff they
have to do for it to get there but it's
you know i mean like it's already a
ripple i guess you can say based on what
we say
and a ripple can happen real fast people
understand how bad like look
xbox
one
if you were going for the 360 era and
you're going from the reputation they
had in the 360 you would think that they
were going to be fine
but
xbox one they made a couple bad
decisions
and the ripple effect happened
and now we're here at the beginning of
the xbox uh series x generation and they
had to spend pretty much five years
fixing that headache
what would you find king what'd you find
i found out that uh tco manufactures and
makes everything about their tvs their
own selves and sony gets uh panels made
from sharp and samsung
yeah so apparently the youtube's having
some issues oh yes
yeah i hope it's not doing it i don't
know sometimes
yeah no no he's not somebody saying no
you guys don't think house mark and
everybody you know no no those guys are
making games how smart you know uh was
it binge do you say been yeah
everybody's making gains what we're
saying is we don't have updates that's
what we're talking about the biggest
update we got from sony
so far was the controller
yeah but they have a lot of stuff
yeah so that that's pretty much
where i stand with that you know i think
we need to see a little bit more on that
i don't think you know i know people
like to
like to to clown they bought a they they
bought a a mobile company and you know
microsoft's buying publishers
i see that all right i see that but i
think we need to see a little bit more
in terms of what's going to happen in
the seasons
and how your wallet uh tells you to move
they
stop acting like uh sony has microsoft
cash they don't no
nobody
all right so let's go ahead and get into
uh let's get into the next topic man uh
king we we we generally do like this
game and i'm kind of curious what your
opinion on the matter is
um
last of us part one you know we just got
the metacritic score uh today it's
actually uh scoring lower than its
predecessors and it's supposed to be a
better game and all
uh but you know that's besides the fact
let me i'm doing a little bit things
behind close uh behind the scenes to try
to fix the stream a little bit king stop
man
[Laughter]
i pull up
so what i what i want to know from you
guys is you know
do you think that
this is a direct response from just like
the lack of trying when it comes to this
expansion
well i mean
of this remake because i feel like a lot
of people felt burnt a little bit
no
i mean i'm buying it
i mean you're mine there are people
buying it people were are getting it
regardless i i'm not i'm skipping this
one i'm waiting for that
price you're out boy yeah me talking
about it i'm not buying the day one i
think it's getting day one
we're just talking about that i'm
getting black friday or whatever i'm
gonna buy did you like everything
yeah yeah i'll cop it for sure but but
not for 70 dollars and for what we're
seeing it looks good they showed off all
the comparisons
yeah like even the dock scene like oh
they showed the dock and how they redid
the houses
yeah really good the water physics all
that stuff's great but it's like
that's really it it's the same thing
coffee i'm a grappler
man i'm not looking for nothing
different man dress up better boo hey go
get that bbl let's make it happen baby
i'm down for the situation now how ready
are you for that spider man that's my
anticipated lesson which one part 2 part
2
and wolverine short turnaround short
turnaround
short turnaround i expect it to look
like oh we lost the whole thing
it's show up
and my joint went to a commercial it
never does that um refreshing nice look
my listen
i expect it to look like miles morales i
thought miles morales was uh upgrade
over
the man i didn't buy the remaster so i
can't say i fraud it and did that
because i played the first one and and i
don't know if i platinum i don't care
anyway yeah
yeah
yo you lost your password did you lose
your bathroom i lost okay i lost the
email see this is this is how disgusting
oh the playstation is when it came to
upgrading xbox i i did it with all my
xboxes you know i sell my old consoles
right and then get the new one right i
don't need it you traded it yeah you
told me that y'all believe in
generations will be moving forward so my
stupid behind goes in there i traded in
i wasn't using it anyway i'm like go
ahead now less is a special editing
console i couldn't get my hands on a
spider-man joint and i really wanted it
that that black and uh i mean the red
and blue one
really wanted it yeah um
so i went got rid of it
i go
to log into my account
i forgot the email
right so i'm thinking you just call
customer service i'm always getting the
run around bro and even when it comes to
a text to agent text agent i don't know
what email it is and i give them my
playstation uh tag they probably think
i'm trolling is xbox three six the lover
oh one look it up my name is attached to
it everything's attached to it i have
two games only that i brought digital
and this is this is why i'm super heated
i brought the last of us too
which is my favorite game yeah on the
playstation platform yeah and i brought
um
ghost to sashimi
and i never buy digital with these dudes
and i did it and it's coming back to
bite me so i'm probably gonna have to
change my name or whatever but that's
not a rant on that
i'm gonna get this game and i'm gonna
buy a physical because i don't trust
sony my my my yeah yeah
um
but i see the hard work naughty dog did
in this right
and
the the fact that it lacks a multiplayer
component and with the multiplayer
component was a huge part of the
original release and it was at full
price at that point in time i think it
was like 59.99
um
it was justified in the price
it's like every time they revise this
game or remake this game or do something
to it loses a little bit of its soul
going forward right but it's pretty in
itself up
um like the remaster for the ps4 it just
looked sharper yeah i mean they made it
look sharper that was about it it's the
same thing same same experience sharper
yeah
this one you're getting this full fledge
like damn
good good like actually like the last
one soon i was like okay looks good you
know but what about the mechanics
whoa
that was the first thing i asked for i
was okay because he said modernized
gameplay
yeah he still uses all the haptics so
you get all that stuff but i'm like
so that's okay so what you do is you add
the ten dollars to that right so you say
if it was uh 59.99 it's 60 bucks and
then you add the 10 to it that's the 10
tax that's that's the tax right there i
mean
but the biggest problem is they took out
the multiplayer right yes
yeah and they're telling us to wait a
year for the new multiplayer now king
let me throw this at you because the new
multiplayer is dropping next year right
what if they do a bundle with this i
will punch somebody in the face you see
what i'm saying
yeah exactly because if you had that
game you bought day one or you just
bought it in general you should get that
for free because that you know it's a
separate experience
but i think a bundle it's happening i
believe so like they like that's such a
dirty look i really do think it's
happening because we already know deep
down you know especially last of us 2 is
going to get a remake
it's going to for just a pc re-release
it's going to happen but it's coming
yeah that multiplayer that multiplayer
as a service gamepl think they want to i
think they want to go free to play with
that you understand they i think they
hope so
money i think they want that money if
you're smart you go free to play yeah
absolutely absolutely you let that go
but i
something tells me deep down you're
gonna have to get a bundle and it's
gonna say yeah the definitive ultimate
experience
i think it's like
i think they will burn themselves
yeah i don't think they will they're
gonna do is justify well look the
multiplayer looks more shiny
right now
i think all the games that they have as
games as a service is free to play model
yeah i think so and i think that's
that's i think attic said it before i
think those games are the ones that
they're going to push inside their
service that that browser thing um and
it's going to be in there and it won't
be in steam you know uh
with the trophies like i think the
trophies i think the reason why
they they they have uh they picked up
savage and you know they have nexus and
i think they have nexus and savage work
hand in hand together and and um
combining the services across the boards
yeah and i don't think those services
will be allowed inside steam i think you
can still get the games in steam yeah
play the games this team but you won't
get your achievements your trophies and
your stuff like that
launcher unless they're working with
steam and that's where that that
launcher comes to play you have a you
know your uh account linked and that's
going to be part of the
i think what's called playstation beyond
the console yeah initiative you know i'm
talking about where it's the center and
it's brand new
it makes sense because a one accounts
multiple devices you know i mean like
you go through it and you can have like
that other like microsoft yeah i don't
know if you could do the sharing thing i
don't know if they're going to have some
no things to play they don't tell me
when you have the multiple you know
multiple accounts you sign in and you
get it yeah i don't think they're gonna
they're gonna do it right now yes sorry
about that i had to like see i do like
oh i i
what i'll do is like cropped out like
zoom and stuff and sometimes
occasionally what will happen is youtube
will decide you know what we ain't gonna
work right so that i have to use my
tools to pull back the stream okay
instead of making the stream look clean
i'm gonna have to just use one zoom
and not crop anything because what's
really going on is i'm having three
zooms run simultaneously together
we had four hundred people they're
coming
they're yeah sometimes well so what it
was the the stream kept dropping in and
out so it's just like all right since
youtube's messing up i'm gonna have to
go with just one zoom and uh it's it it
seems like it's stabilizing i don't know
what was going on sometimes zoom b
sometimes youtube be like that i don't
know
youtube
then the time just
so you know
when it comes to last of us you know i
definitely
i
i don't see nothing with it now i do
think it's weird about the trophy
situation and stuff in general um but
it's just like i think
those kind of scenarios just happen
and
i don't really look at them too much now
if last of us two i do think it's crazy
what the
with the
the door knocking in thing
i think that's crazy uh but as far as
anything else it doesn't really sit too
well with me it is what it is we'll have
to see exactly what happens in the
future
um but you know let's go ahead and
briefly talk about death loop uh because
you know clearly youtube's still having
issues i want to go ahead and
pass through these a little bit uh let
me get these super chats real quick i
apologize i don't know you you guys know
how youtube is sometimes yeah it happens
rubber not shut the vvr off it's
wrecking the street
hashtag save the tcl
sponsor your stream today yeah you got a
two dollar super drive from flame
playstation shoes are now in 88 loops
sorry had to
wow
two dollars from tech money a lot of
games that should be 23 will be 24.25
now wow
guys are crazy man you guys are crazy
all right so let's let's talk about
death loop
that's a playstation exclusive that is
owned by microsoft
a lot of us expected that it would come
to the microsoft platform now
it doesn't look like that's going to
happen um you know maybe not now
people expected it next month but tell
me how when the the contract ends it
goes on to the playstation plus now
to me king i don't know how you feel
about that but to me
i see that as sony knows they're about
to lose that marketing deal
and they're coming in the back door i'm
like okay right out the back door we're
gonna put it in the extra tier because
we know
next month we won't have any control
over this brand
what do you feel i think that's the best
thing that you can do i think that's
exactly how you fight i think that's
that's showing that you still got teeth
you know um for the for your fan base
that didn't purchase the game
uh you get a chance to hey man listen
you're not missing out it's gonna be
available on the xbox platform
and um maybe they have something written
in the contract where it can't go
straight to game pass right there while
it's on the playstation
service
listen microsoft uses the same dirty
tactics on their end
and and i tell you all is fear in love
and war
you don't go down you don't go down easy
pause you know you you you fight man you
you fight tooth and nail because if
somebody has a superior product you got
to show value inside your product i
don't care how it goes you don't let it
get off your platform that easy you see
how microsoft had um
all the yakuza games leave in mass
exodus at one time they turned right
back around and got them all back in so
you're right man you're right they got
all it was like it was like two weeks it
was like it was like they were probably
a grandstand when it come to contracting
and then it's just like they agreed to
okay just throw the ball back on let's
see
you got to say what else is with that
because right after that we got persona
5 and all these other games that's
coming in and with that so they had to
double down with this bread right you
got to do what you got to do to keep
your fan base because a lot of dudes are
probably in the middle of playing the
yakuza games and was like damn and they
gone right i gotta go buy them those two
weeks maybe some dudes brought then they
come right back
i'm telling you this if the game is
leaving out of your ecosystem
and you have a fan base that is going to
be an uproar you don't have nothing they
don't have nothing around this period of
time
you keep you keep the zeitgeist you keep
that there oh this is launching in our
our service good
it you should show value in your service
so your service got to be strong if you
if you're charging 18 a month
and microsoft is about to launch their
service at damn near five dollars a
person
yeah
show value
so
microsoft can't put inside game pass
just yet we could and we can keep it all
for game pass for as long as possible
give them the money to keep the game
there i don't care what you do to do it
i think that's a great idea it's
fantastic regardless to what i'm gonna
play it at some time first of all let me
tell you let me say one thing the field
dominance maximus are really expensive
this is the last time i doubt you sir
the the last time i doubt you i brought
a model phoenix rising
as they had it on sale my stupid behind
went and purchased it it's in game pass
yesterday
dear god
dear god how many times must the king
have to bend the knee to game pass and
watch his digital cash just flutter in
space
not doing it no more i'm just going to
sit back relax and wait for the stuff to
show up i'm not doing it no more
save my money for fortnight
[Laughter]
yeah yeah addict
[Music]
of integration yeah
dragon ball z into it i'm talking about
every aspect of dragon ball z
yeah and and they show
we're sitting i'm watching cartoons
straight just not even playing the game
watching shows we're talking about like
the legit cartoon the legit show
and
you can do it with your headsets on
talking to people
it's ill it's ill where we
as
as
from where this medium came from right
right you know such a small thing to
this global
it's insane how many
deals they've had even with avengers
what the thin [ __ ] murdered that what
thanos and the offending gun they had so
much stuff the black hole things this is
this is crazy this is a phenomenon that
i don't know how it stops
but
it's it's it's it's absolutely not so
yeah i'm addicted to that the attic was
talking to me today he's like you know
fortnight later
damn i got stuff i got to do my girl
looked right at me and was like
no you ain't
[Laughter]
but yeah yeah um
yeah i actually really like death loop i
think it was a fantastic game there's
actually review for it on this channel
uh you know
loved it yeah experienced it um i i
thought it was a fantastic playstation
exclusive i think it's a good example of
what arcane can do for microsoft in the
future if they're properly funded and
you know it's just i think that stuff
like that stuff like psychonauts
starfield you know these games were
bought at the tail end of their
development and even some games uh you
know like death loop didn't really
benefit the xbox brand because it was on
a competing platform uh what they don't
show in exclusivity they show in
what these games have to offer and what
the developers have to offer for the
xbox brand what their future games can
actually do and i think if you look at
these games there's no denying it that
you know these are very talented studios
and you're going to see them continue
this drive now obviously you're seeing
stuff
that some of these studios make that
some of you might not like uh for
instance i know that uh
same grounded not a big grounded fan uh
but i do recognize that
if you don't give these to everybody
it's not even that if you don't give
these developers creativity to exercise
that muscle
then they're going to go somewhere else
that they can
that's true and that is part of the
point in keeping and retaining these
talented individuals is sometimes like
look
we might clown on the passion project
some of us might not like some of them i
prefer
uh obsidian to make rpgs
but
when you give someone
the ability to make something that
they've been really passionate about
the chances of him going away is pretty
low at that point he's probably gonna
stay around because he gives that
ability and i think that's what we need
to really focus on more is the fact that
they do have these
features and death will come to xbox
eventually i i mean i'm calling it's a
great game it's a great game has a great
story the um overall voice acting some
of the best
in that game too it's really really it's
a really really good game i thought it
was going to be uh
i had my doubts when i went and played
it i was like you know what ended up
being one of my most uh enjoyed games of
that year it was
very very good yes so you know ain't
nothing really talk talk about that man
uh
i do appreciate everything up there
we're gonna go ahead and get this last
topic out the way man we're gonna get
the last topic
xbox
family game for xbox family and friends
game pass
there's a lot of uh people who
i think it's interesting the name
it's a very interesting name i'm kind of
curious why they chose that name i kind
of feel like they're b they knew that
people used game sharing the weight
wasn't originally intended to and they
didn't want people i know people that
want game share because they feel they
think it's illegal they literally dead
ass think it's illegal uh because it
wasn't
initially used the way that it that you
know the way microsoft promoted it as so
i think that's the reason they want to
come out openly one and have strong
wording strong phrases
that's like
you guys can use this with your friends
i'm interested because
rumored right now would be 25
uh do you guys one think that's a very
valid
price point we'll start with big cloud
and two do you think this is going to
amp up those those numbers especially if
you know within the next year and a half
to two years we might see a price
increase with gamepad because i think we
are we are coming close to that we're
coming close to a price increase like
uh if it's 25 i don't think you're gonna
see the price increase yet especially
after what sony just did it's all about
optics at this point you stay away from
that i think they're gonna do that price
increase when you start seeing the uh
stuff drop for game pass like the the
good stuff like you know so that people
were waiting for like the ad division
and uh everything else but i don't think
you're gonna see the price drop uh price
increase yet
but it's it's good it looks good do you
think that
with something like this it would be
more
because i do think there's a lot of
people that would do game pass
but they're not
able to they they you know it's one
thing to ask someone for a dollar ask
someone to do something for free first
off you got to put your credit card
information a lot of people feel very
weird doing that they don't want to do
that anymore they do like i like mine
like even on ps1 i do that p-power join
i don't put my you know a lot of people
don't have credit cards yeah
so i think it's a lot easier to be like
yo
add me on to your to your family plan
i'll toss you that money every month
yeah right it's smart it's a smart way
of getting those numbers it's like cool
it's it's a nice way of doing it like
i'm
all for it uh what they're doing this
now they're probably going to like it
based off your um
probably if you're a region if remember
correctly unless it's
they're opening it all the way up i'm
not sure but
25 again it's that's a steal you get
what like five accounts four accounts
yeah isn't that like ironically isn't
that similar to what netflix does in the
high tier you got like four devices or
five devices so
yeah it's all right
yeah it's about right yeah you and you
make it in your own yeah that's fine
what do you think king i because i know
me and you we did a little skit on iop
last sunday which you know first of all
i want to i want to thank everyone for
the the the welcoming of the the lord's
going to tech talk uh you know that they
we posted a little bit yeah we on tick
tock now uh and what's funny is i i was
cutting it up man
i didn't realize
it's on tick tock you got a yeah yeah i
didn't realize
king
how funny that child support segment was
[Music]
support like you know
i think that
this is ex accessibly useful when it
comes to
you know
widespread families people that did that
didn't rap before they tapped it in
their 20s now they got 10 15 kids you
know i think uh you know this is this is
definitely something good what do you
think kia king what do you think i think
this this is this is for the families
you know um
if you're a gamer and the majority of
the people that are growing up now
has been around games are are in games
right
uh we come from
let's say the last uh
20 to 30 years if you're in that that
bracket you know you're 20 30 years old
you should have a stable job at this
point in time
um you should have been exposed to video
games in some form or fashion uh you
probably at the point where you're
starting a family or in in or in the
middle of a family or you're joining a
family or or
you have siblings that are off to school
and they don't have the the cash at that
point in time
to to to to buy games yeah right this is
what i do with my son i have i have two
kids in college um and i have a son
that's here
and
what i do is
me and him was game sharing anyway
you know um that and i saved on that and
i have uh both daughters game share
right
so
you're looking at uh
i thought you only had one son see look
at you no no i got i got two sons oh
my oldest son
uh this i'm going to add him when i buy
the
the family thing
yo listen let me throw something your
way you know because he already starting
his family he had no kids yet but you
know he has a girlfriend and i'm pretty
sure at some point in time you're gonna
slip up so um yeah yeah throw this to
you so cuz diapers ain't cheap um throw
him a game pass you know alley-oop to
him
you know i i think
somebody at microsoft looked at all the
models that were out there all the
business models and netflix's being the
one of the primary uh business models
when it comes to streaming it's not the
same medium but
it's adjacent and
the fact that you can look at it and you
say listen i get a one subscription on
the highest tier and you get four
different devices netflix knew you was
cheating before anyway oh yeah what they
did was they allowed you to do it they
raised the price to make it affordable
for